I'm going to show you how to make a
do-it-yourself face mask for 20 cents
that will work better than any cream out
there. It's inexpensive, super
anti-aging. It's going to tighten your
skin, nourish your skin. If you have any
darker scars or darker blemishes, it'll
lighten those up. It's going to also
help if you have any acne or a little
red dots. It's going to make your skin
look very youthful and healthy. And at
the end of this video, you're going to
add one more thing which will cost you
nothing extra to take your skin to the
next level. And this video is very
short, so you're going to want to watch
the whole thing. What are we going to
use as a face mask? The answer is the
clear part of the egg. You're simply
going to take the white of the egg, put
it in a bowl, do a little whisking, and
then you're going to apply a very thin
layer to your skin on your face. Wait 15
to 20 minutes until it dries. It's going
to tighten everything up. It's going to
make your skin look and feel really
youthful. That's pretty simple, right?
Well, now we're going to add one more
thing to take it to the next level.
Let's see if you can guess what this is.
This extra thing is super high in
something that a lot of people are
deficient in. Vitamin A. The more you're
deficient in vitamin A, the rougher your
skin is going to be. Is loaded with
vitamin A and vitamin D, E, K, B
vitamins, and choline, which are all
wonderful for your skin. If you guessed
egg yolk,
>> that answer is correct.
>> I mean, you're already adding the egg
white. Why not just throw in the yolk?
Because the white handles the tightening
factor on the skin and the wrinkles, but
the yolk actually gives nutrition into
the skin directly, especially with the
vitamin A and these other nutrients.
Then you're going to rinse off the
entire egg with warm water and gently
dry it with a towel. Do this two times a
week. Adding the egg yolk actually adds
a healing factor and a regenerative
factor. You may want to add a teaspoon
of yogurt to this mix just to add some
additional things that will help with
your microbiome on the skin. Just make
sure that the yogurt is not sweetened.
You want organic plain yogurt. This is a
very, very inexpensive but awesome thing
you can do to help with anti-aging on
your skin. Doing this once or twice a
week. I would also recommend eating more
eggs in your diet. I personally eat four
eggs every single day, okay, for one of
my meals. If you're a female, maybe you
have three or two, but I know other
females that have five eggs every single
day. Consuming eggs are like a
superfood. It's the highest quality
protein that you can eat. If you're
going to fry the egg, uh fry it in olive
oil or butter or even coconut oil. Do
not use regular corn oil or other seed
oils. This way, we can attack the skin
from two ways. from the outside in and
then from the inside out. Now that you
know how to use this face mask on your
skin, now let's go a little deeper. I
want to show you how to heal your skin
from the inside out. And to take your
skin from the next level, to heal it
from the inside out, watch this video
right now. This one right there. Click
it.
Hey, before you leave, I just wanted to
give you a little quick history on some
of the books that I wrote. This was one
of the first books. It's called Dr. Ber
body shapes. It was my attempt at um
writing about body types. Uh what was
very interesting about this book is I
actually did all the images myself. Uh
don't ask me why. Um they look actually
not quite as professional as some of the
uh images that I have in the new book.
But anyway, this is my first attempt
right here called Dr. Berg's Body Shape
Diets. Uh and then I wrote a book um
more extensive called The Seven
Principles of Fat Burning. I don't even
have a copy anymore actually um because
it's outdated. Uh the next book uh I put
about a thousand hours into this one
right here called The New Body Type
Guide. Major updates on the body types.
Uh I put a lot of energy into this. Uh
it has professional images, graphics,
all sorts of things. Now, the problem
with this book is it doesn't really
describe what this is really about. Body
types are only a small portion of what's
in this book. And that's why I changed
the name to the healthy keto plan. Okay?
If you happen to have this book, you
don't really need this book because
there's some only very very minor
updates. But if you don't have this, you
need to get this one right here. Um,
this book goes into every single detail
that you would ever want to know about.
It goes into the seven principles of fat
burning. goes into hormones, uh the body
types, the basic keto plan, it goes into
intermittent fasting. I talk about the
10 fat burning triggers and blockers and
fat burning strategies with a lot of
details in every single chapter. I go
into body issues that interfere with
losing weight. Um there's very few
people that just have a weight problem.
They have a lot of body issues, whether
it's sleeping problems, uh stress
problems, inflammation,
menopause. I cover that extensively in
this book. Then I talk about how to get
rid of stress and I show you a
technique. Uh then I get into exercising
and then I have a lot of really good
recipes in this book as well. So uh this
is a good reference guide um on my
website. If you get this book, you get
this one free. It's called Healthy Keto
Intermittent Fasting. This is the
shortcut uh quick guide to this book.
And uh the reason I created this book is
to have you within 45 minutes learn how
to do keto, okay, in intermittent
fasting, exactly what you need to do.
Then you can fill in the blanks with
this book right here. So right now I'm
doing a special. If you get this book,
you get this one totally free. Or you
can go to Amazon and get these
individually. So I just want to clarify
the difference between this book and
this updated one right here. If you
don't have this, you need to get this
right here. That way you can get the
exact correct information to do it
healthily.